welcome to the presentation on
multiplying fractions well I think today
you'll be very happy because you'll find
out that this is one of the few times
where multiplying something is easier
than adding it I think or or subtracting
it for that matter and then if you don't
believe me let's do some problems okay
let's get started let's let's do let's
start with 1/2 times 1/2 so when you
multiply fractions it's very
straightforward it's essentially just
two separate multiplication problems you
multiply the numerators so you get one
times one and you multiply the
denominators 2 times 2 1 times 1 is 1
2 times 2 is 4 so 1/2 times 1/2 is equal
to 1/4 and that makes sense
that's like saying 1/2 of 1/2 is 1/4
which makes sense what if we had
negative numbers well if add 1/2 times
negative 1/2 and when you have a
negative fraction it's good to describe
the negative number I tend to describe
the negative number to the numerator
it's negative 1 over 2 you realize that
negative 1/2 is the same thing as
negative 1 over 2 hopefully that makes
sense so 1/2 times negative 1/2 that's
just the same thing as 1 times negative
1 over 2 times 2 which equals negative 1
over 4 which is the same thing as
negative 1/4 what if I had different
denominators and when you're adding and
subtracting fractions that that tends to
make things difficult well it's not not
necessarily the case here if I had 2/3
times 1/2 just multiply the numerators 2
times 1 and you multiply the
denominators 3 times 2 so you get 2
times 1 is 2 3 times 2 is 6 and 2 over 6
we know from equivalent fractions the
same thing as 1/3
that was an interesting problem let's do
it again and I want to show you a little
trick here so 2 over 3 times 1/2 as you
said any multiplication problem you just
multiply the numerators multiply the
denominators and you have your answer
but sometimes yet there's a little trick
here where you can say you can cancel
out you can divide the numerators and
the denominators by a number because you
know this is going to be the same thing
as 2 times 1 over 3 times 2 which is the
same thing I'm just switching the order
on top is 1 times 2 over 3 times 2 right
all I did is I switch the order on top
because you can multiply in either
direction and that's the same thing as 1
3 times 2 over 2 well that just is 1/3
times 1 which is equal to 1/3 and why
did I do that well I want to show you
that these twos these twos all I did is
switch the order but at all times we had
1 2 in the numerator and had 1 2 in the
denominator if I wanted to and this is
kind of a trick for for doing
multiplication really fast so you don't
have to reduce the final fraction too
much you get 2/3 times 1/3 you'd say oh
I got 1 2 3 times 1/2 sorry you see I
have a 2 in the numerator 2 in the
denominator let me divide them both by 2
that equals 1/3 just a fast trick I hope
I didn't confuse you let's do a couple
more problems and I'll do it both with
the trick and without the trick what if
I had 3/7 times 2 over 5 well multiply
the numerators 3 times 2 is 6 7 times 5
is 35 that's it let's do it with some
negative numbers if I had negative 3
over 4 times 2 over 11 well that's
negative 6 over 44 which is the same
thing as negative 3 over 22 and we could
have done that cross dividing trick here
let's do it again with the cross
times two over eleven we say oh well two
and four they're both divisible by two
so let's divide them both by 2 so 2
becomes 1 & 4 becomes 2 and then our
answer becomes minus 3 over 22 right
negative 3 times 1 is minus 3 2 times 11
is 22 let's do another one right here if
I had negative 2/5 times minus 2/5
well that just is equal to negative 2
times negative 2 is positive 4 and 5
times 5 is 25
4 for 25 and let's just remember
negative times a negative is a positive
which makes sense let's just do a couple
more problems since we have a lot of
time but I think you've probably got
this by now
you're probably realizing that
multiplying fractions is a lot easier
than adding them or subtracting them
hopefully like this it's not a bad thing
if you find adding or subtracting
fractions easy as well let's do I'm just
making up numbers now 2 ninths times 18
over - well here we could do we could
well we have a to of the numerator a
tuned denominator let's both let's
divide them both by 2 so they both
become 1 and we have an 18 in the
numerator and a 9 in the denominator
well they both are divisible by 9 so
let's divide them both by 9 so 9 becomes
a 1 and the 18 becomes a 2 so we have 1
times 2 over 1 times 1 well that just
equals 2 over 1 which equals 2 that was
pretty straightforward we could have
done it I guess you'd call it the hard
way if we said 2 times 2 over 9 times 18
over 2 2 times 18 is 36 9 times 2 is 18
and 36 divided by 18 we can see 18 goes
into 36 2 times that also equals 2
either way is fine if you don't feel
comfortable doing this trick right now
you don't have to all that does is it
makes it easier it makes you won't end
up with huge numbers in your product
that you'll have to figure out if they
can be reduced further
let's do two more problems - 5 over 7
times 1 over 3 minus 5 times 1 is minus
5 7 over 3 is 21 that's it let me do one
more of the cross with the the little
trick I showed you let's say I had 15
and here I think you'll see why that
trick is useful over 21 times 14 over 5
well clearly if we multiply this out we
end up with with pretty big numbers I
think is what 220 over 105 and then you
have to reduce those becomes a big mess
but we can see that 15 and 5 are both
divisible by 5 so let's divide them both
by 5 so 15 divided by 5 is 3 5 divided
by 5 is 1 14 and 21 they're both
divisible by 7 14 divided by 7 is 2 21
divided by 7 is 3 and so we get 3 times
2 is 6 over 3 times 1 is 3 which equals
2 and that's the same thing as what I
said before if we had multiplied 15
times 14 that would have been 2 to 10 I
think yeah 15 times 14 is 210 and 21
times 5 would have been 105 and you
would have to fit fit you would have to
say I guess in this case it's kind of
obvious that what - 10 is 2 times 105
and you've gotten 2 as well so hopefully
I didn't confuse you too much with that
last problem but I hope you realize
multiplications pretty straightforward
you just multiply the numerators you
multiply the denominators and then if
you have to reduce you reduce but you're
pretty much done I think you're ready
now to try the multiplication module and
I hope you have fun